biden is getting [ __ ] on right now yeah
uh for trying to provide clean
crack pipes yes
why is that bad
because it's an opportunity to morally
grandstand for the other side yeah
that's all it is it's [ __ ] irritating
it's their opportunity to run with this
headline and say joe biden look what
he's doing to our country he's just
handing out crack pipes to people who's
saying what like the republicans like
this yeah there's also news conservative
news what is joe biden doing to america
the headline i saw today was joe biden
hands out crack pipes and black
communities for quote racial equity
yeah you gotta respect the title that's
gonna get clicked yeah yeah that's good
that's great yeah yeah
yeah i mean that was phenomenal
yeah i have to read that article yeah
hands out
yeah yeah it sounds like he's doing it
he's like walking around
like they're turkeys on thanksgiving
there's just a big [ __ ] u-haul that
he has crack pipes in he's like the
tooth fairy but for crack bro he just
[ __ ] yeah he goes in the house slips
under the pillow keeps it moving
damn okay now the real story is
that uh they were handing out these uh
care packages yes right and uh they they
want to incentivize drug addicts not to
use needles because needles is where you
have actual what well it was like just a
proposal and that was one of the things
so like they're trying to yeah the care
packages they're doing clean needles too
yeah so clean needles but they're like
if we can give these crack pipes out
ideally they won't switch from smoking
into shooting it because when they're
shooting and they're sharing the needles
that's where aids and uh what's the
other one
hepatitis hepatitis gets shared etc um
they also said like the uh broken up
crack pipes you can get like cuts and
all this other stuff that causes these
weird infections and basically they
think like if you can do drugs in a
safer way it will create a guess a safer
community and less spread of disease etc
and probably make it easier to come back
from that addiction coming back from
that addiction when you already got
hepatitis and [ __ ] aids is going to
be a lot harder it's true and this
program or programs like this have been
around for a really long time for a long
time and it probably also like it's less
cost on us for health care yeah the guy
goes in and he's got aids cost us that
much more money so charlemagne had an
interesting point where he was just like
yo when are we gonna stop when are we
gonna start blaming democrats for their
bad messaging
it's like you put out the messaging yeah
you said that he did this like if i'm
them i'm not even saying anything i'm
not even making this a [ __ ] headline
like if it has me
saying okay to giving out fresh crack
pipes to the people in these areas
i know how that could be taken from the
opposition and turned into a tool to
punish me i'm not even saying anything
about it slow rolling into the proposal
i in order to so they put the proposal
forward mm-hmm and in the process they
have 11 things they have infectious
disease kits safe sex kits sharps
disposal kit syringe prevention blah
blah vaccination services all this [ __ ]
screening for infectious disease and
then one of them is just safe smoking
kit supplies so it doesn't actually say
crack pipe
it says safe smoking kits supplies which
more or less means crack bite but the
wording is they're trying to
hide it inside them
who decides like the best way to make a
crack pipe
like there's a focus group that the
government has to hire to be like okay
this is the most efficient way to make a
crash pipeline it's going to take some
years off a drug dealer sentence yeah
maybe 100 right like it's not like
they're just giving you a little piece
of glass like they are printing these
[ __ ] things it's like when they hire
leo and catch me if you can yes let's
get the best crack pipe maker who's in
jail and have him make crack pipes for
the crackheads yeah if you had an
infinite budget how would you make a
crack yeah are we going to make better
crack smokers
like shouldn't doing crack be hard
they're like you should burn your
fingers right it should make cuts on
your mouth so you don't do it you
shouldn't like start smoking crack and
you're like this is enjoyable yeah it
shouldn't be [ __ ] freeze pipe for
crack right like
it shouldn't be yeah yeah that's i mean
yeah but also i don't you wanna it's
like handing out condoms in high school
yeah yeah you gotta prevent the
pregnancy because we don't want the [ __ ]
downstream yeah and these are the same
people that would get upset about that
it's just no dude
the numbing condoms that numb you on the
inside
i've done those but yeah it numbs you
and then you're like man sex is boring
well loki i think the the nyc we were
talking about this on brilliance but the
nyc subway condom i actually think that
that uh had diminishing returns
the nyc uh new york city made like
condoms counters for free and they were
just giving out for free but they were
so uncomfortable
that you were just like if that was the
first condom you ever use you're going
oh i'm not using condoms these shits
suck the first condom you use has to
feel as close to sex as possible so you
go i'll just have protected sex
like do you remember yeah they were
thick and like you didn't feel tight
it was just awful
and i remember i'd rather risk it
than go soft on a girl
because that's the real that's the real
issue right it's like with wearing a
condom is the embarrassment of not
feeling it and either not coming or
[ __ ] softening up
so as a dude your ego is going to take
over and you're using it
i'm definitely not failing right there
but your ego is probably taking a hit
pulling out of mta conor mon in the
first place
you never pulled it out hit her with a
yeah dude
i remember them shits yeah
they said mta on it yeah yeah bro come
on yeah and i had like a different
train stop really yeah and like
that's how you get home after you just
take the referee but like the fact that
they think that we like the subway so
much we're like yeah that's where i want
to [ __ ] like it had to be somebody
outside of new york city oh yeah like
there's so many other things that you
could do
yeah and make and brand economy around
the empire state building
big hard structure
the rockefeller economy right like some
fire [ __ ] that you want on your dick
like i want my dick to be the empire
[ __ ] state building but the
subway what about the subway is sexual
nothing i mean it's long
i don't know
it comes late bro this just sucks that's
what you don't want in the period you
want the period on time yeah yeah yeah
yeah we can think of the worst reasons
yeah it's filthy full of disease comes
late not reliable uh sometimes there's
other dudes in it already
what's good about it it gets you there
it will get you close yeah that won't
get you exactly where you want to go
it's dirty you could probably get sick
from it yeah you don't want to be there
too long it's the whole yeah nothing is
good nothing marketing yeah sometimes
you start in there and then there's just
some dude sitting next to you for the
rest of it
yeah yeah yeah it's actually the worst
possibility
like a bathroom custodian you know what
i mean like no bathroom constructor is
gonna sell you the condo that says like
bathroom on it no i mean like it's gonna
say trojan or some [ __ ] like give me the
brand name even if you give it in the
subway make it brand name
yeah but even trojan's not that good of
a name yo i thought about this and i'm
sure some comic has done a bit about it
right like but it is possibly the worst
name for a condom like the whole idea of
the trojan horse was you sneak something
in there and then once it's in there
all the little guys inside get let out
yeah which is the last thing you want
from a condom right you want to get
inside and then they don't get out they
just stay in there and then you pull it
out yeah like this horse is comfortable
how the [ __ ] did they why would they not
no
yeah i mean i like the idea of a horse
horse is good horse is cool yeah horse
dick but i think the actual trojan is
the warrior or whatever right which is
also kind of weird the horse is on the
[ __ ] condom the trojan horse is is
the horse yeah isn't this part of the
branding i thought it used to be i think
they took it off but it used to be
that's how old we are
buying them three packs at the bottom
three which ones you go for no i went
for gold pack because just like you
could flex that you'd use in gold pack
and magnum magnums yeah yeah yeah and
it's like being in the club and getting
the bottles and [ __ ] like that's like i
got the gold pack yo and the thing about
magnums where i remember like i remember
the first time that i tried a magnum i
was terrified i was like please let me
fit this magnum and then i looked at it
and i'm like oh it's the same size
they're just charging more so that you
can have a mat you pay a premium so the
girl thinks you have a huge dick yeah
it's the same [ __ ] size
yeah that seems like a good investment
it's a little bigger okay but like
marginally bigger yeah like compare it
with the mta condoms it's different
it's way bigger that's upstairs
mca condoms was one size fits one group
so anyway are you going to get one of
biden's crack pipes
i mean i want i got to get my hands on
one that's what we were talking about
yeah yeah
that's how we got here listen this is
there's no rhyme or reason for anything
yeah uh do you think he did it for his
son
oh my god
that is [ __ ] great it was just like
yo this is my kid anybody knows crack
pipes yeah he's probably the one that's
designing a design finally a job that
he's actually cut out for like he's had
all these government jobs that he has no
experience right like running energy for
ukraine nope painting nope but
crack pipes there you go know the man
for the job yeah there you go there's
only time nepotism's like
sometimes you luck out the most
qualified crack bite maker ever i've
worked my whole life for this
dude
hunter biden is designing the crack
pipes exactly
dude if they aren't joe's a piece of
[ __ ]
i'm just saying finally you have a
position for your son that he actually
deserves that he deserves
could could help people with yeah right
yeah he was doing crack
i thought it was heroin no correct son
he's been smoking it out this is weird
white people doing crackers
no hunter is an ally doug oh respect
yeah
didn't the government put crack in like
black neighborhoods in the first place
yes yeah so this is just them doing
the rest of it did they put it in there
we don't know no they did i mean
honestly when i heard this bill come out
and i was like black people watch out
they're preparing you for another batch
the real economy's tough
start throwing crack in the in the hood
again killing y'all with the opiates
right so yes and they're killing y'all
with the opiates we're killing that we
killing ourselves i mean they kill them
they are killing us yeah it's the
government yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the pharmaceutical companies who aren't
getting any positions
right yeah you smoke meth
uh you can shoot it too
okay so are they doing anything for meth
heads
are they doing any of this kind of no
one cares about that yeah it's white
people dying yeah yeah that is right we
do not care about white people what if
that was the republican outrage what
about the clean meth kids
what about the white people yeah where's
our stuff come on
let's see that's black privilege you
guys give crap
you're
where's our opiates